Welcome to our deep dive, where today you will hear Reza Shakhazemi's spiritual ethos as we let the Imam's own first sermon placed first in the collection sound whole, opening not on law but on the negation of every attribute of God.
The perfection of sincerity toward him is to divest him of all attributes.
We will explore the strange paradox of why this monumental text begins on negation instead of law,
We will listen to the sermon heard whole, and we will follow its single grand arc from the unbounded God down to the creation of a world and back up to the book.
Before we analyze it, we must first hear the text in full.
Praise be to God, whose laudation those who speak cannot deliver, whose graces those who count cannot number, and whose rightful do those whose strides cannot render.
He whom no far-reaching aspiration can attain, and whom no diving depth of understanding can fathom.
He whose attribute has no bounding limit, no existing description, no appointed time, and no extended term.
He originated all created things through His power, scattered the winds through His mercy, and steadied the trembling of His earth with mighty mountains.
The foremost of religion is the knowledge of Him.
The perfection of knowing Him is to believe in Him.
The perfection of believing in Him is to affirm His oneness.
The perfection of affirming His oneness is to be sincere toward Him.
And the perfection of sincerity toward him is to divest him of all attributes.
For every attribute bears witness that it is other than the object it qualifies, and every such object bears witness that it is other than the attribute.
So whoever ascribes an attribute to God, glorified be he, has joined another to him, and whoever joins another to him has made him two.
And whoever makes him two has divided him into parts, and whoever divides him into parts is ignorant of him.
Whoever points to him has confined him.
Whoever confines him has counted him, and whoever asks in what is he, has set him apart.
He is being, but not through any coming to be, existent, but not out of form or nothingness.
He is with everything, but not by association, and other than everything, but not by separation.
He acts, but not through movements or instruments.
He sees, even when there was nothing of his creation to be seen.
He is alone, for there was none whose company he might seek or whose absence he might feel.
He brought forth creation, and originated it from the beginning, without pondering a plan, without profiting from experience, without setting any motion in train, and without the disquiet of any exertion.
He gave each thing its appointed span, harmonized their differences, fixed their natures, and impressed upon them their forms knowing them before he made them, encompassing their bounds and their ends, and aware of what joins them and what parts them.
Then he, glorified be he, cleft the atmospheres, and split the surrounding regions and the layers of air.
Into them he made water flow, its waves surging and swelling heaped upon the back of a violent thunderous wind.
He commanded the wind to hold the water back and gave it power over the fury of its currents, setting it against the water's bounds, air beneath it spread wide, water above it pouring in flood.
Then he raised up another wind and made it barren, holding it long in its place, driving hard its course and reaching it out far and wide.
He ordered it to stir the deep waters and to churn the waves of the sea until it beat them as a milkskin is beaten and drove them on in the open air as it had driven them in the void, turning their first back upon their last.
There still upon their moving until the water rose in a heaped mass and lifted up a froth.
This froth he raised into the open and empty air, and made of it the seven heavens.
The lowest a stayed wave held back, the highest a roof upheld, and a vault raised high, with no pillar to prop them and no nail to bind them.
Then he adorned them with the ornament of stars and the light of shooting meteors, and hung within them a shining lamp and a luminous moon, in a turning orbit, a moving vault and a wheeling firmament.
Then he parted the heights of the heavens, and filled them with kinds of his angels.
Among them are those who prostrate and do not bow, and those who bow and do not stand, and those who stand in ranks and never break them, and those who glorify him and never weary.
No slumber of the eye overtakes them, no wandering of the mind, no weakness of the body, no forgetful heedlessness.
Among them are the trustees of his revelation, and the tongues that carry his word to his messengers, and those who come and go with his decree and his command.
Among them are the guardians of his servants and the keepers of the gates of his gardens.
Among them are those whose feet are fixed in the lowest depths of the earth, while their necks pass beyond the highest heaven, whose limbs reach past the ends of the world, and whose shoulders are matched to the pillars of the throne.
Their eyes are lowered beneath it, and they have wrapped themselves in their wings beneath it, and between them and all below them are veils of majesty and curtains of might.
They do not picture their Lord in any form, nor ascribe to him the marks of things made, nor confine him within places, nor point to him by any likeness.
Then he, glorified be he, gathered a handful of the earth, of the hard and the soft, the sweet and the salt, and poured water over it until it was cleansed, and kneaded it with moisture until it held.
From it he shaped a figure with curves and joints, limbs and parts.
He said it till it tried, and hardened it until it rang, for a known term and an appointed end.
Then he breathed into it of his spirit, and arose up a human being, endowed with minds to govern its thought, with limbs to serve it, with instruments to wield, and with a knowing by which to tell the truth from the false, taste from taste, and color from color, of being needed of clashing natures and gather opposites, of heat and cold, of moisture and dryness.
Then God asked of the angels the discharge of the trust he had laid on them and the keeping of the covenant of his command, that they bow down before Adam in submission and lower themselves before his honor.
So he said, Prostrate yourselves before Adam.
And they prostrated all save Iblis.
Pride seized him and wretchedness overcame him.
He gloried in his own making of fire and scorned the creature of clay.
So God granted him respite, that his wrath might be earned in full and the trial completed and the promise fulfilled.
And he said, You are among those reprieved until the day of the appointed time.
Then he settled Adam in a dwelling where his life was made pleasant and his abode secure, and he warned him of iblis and his enmity.
But the enemy deceived him, begrudging him his lasting home and his fellowship with the righteous.
And Adam bartered certainty for doubt and resolve for weakness, and took tread in place of gladness and remorse in place of pride.
Then God spread his repentance before him, taught him the word of his mercy, and promised him return to his garden and sent him down to the abode of trial and the begetting of children.
From among Adam's children God chose prophets and took their pledge upon his revelation and the delivering of his message, at a time when most of his creatures had broken their covenant with him, ignored his right, and set up rivals beside him, and the devils had turned them from the knowledge of him and cut them off from his worship.
So he sent among them his messengers and raised up his prophets one after another, as to call them to fulfill the covenant of their creation, to remind them of his forgotten gift, to argue with them by the delivering of the message, to stir up for them of the buried treasures of the intellect, and to show them the signs of his power.
The sky spread above them, the earth laid beneath them, the means of their living, the deaths that carry them off, the ills that age them, and the events that follow upon them.
God did not leave his creation without a sent prophet.
a revealed book, a binding proof, or a clear Rd.
His messengers were never made helpless by their small number or by the throng of those who called them liars.
To each earlier one, the name of the one to come was given, and by each later one, the one before was made known.
So the generations passed and the ages ran on.
Fathers went and sons came after them until God sent Muhammad, his messenger, to fulfill his promise and complete his prophethood, his pledge already taken from the prophets, his signs well known, his birth noble.
The people of the earth in his day were of scattered creeds, divided desires and warring ways, some likening God to his creation, some twisting his names, some pointing to another than him.
By him God guided them out of error and by his standing among them delivered them from ignorance.
Then God chose for Mohammed the meeting with himself, and was pleased to bring him near, and honored him by taking him away from the abode of this world and the place of trial.
He drew him to himself in honor, and left among you what the prophets left to their communities, for they do not abandon them unattended, without a plain Rd.
and a standing beacon.
He left the book of your Lord among you.
Setting forth it's lawful and it's forbidden, it's obligatory and it's recommended, it's abrogating and abrogated, it's permitted and it's enjoined, it's particular and it's general, it's lessons and its parables, it's unbound and it's bound, it's clear and it's obscure unfolding what it packed close and clarifying what it left dark.
In it are matters whose knowledge is bound upon the servants and matters whose ignorance is forgiven them.
Things it sets down as obligatory that the practice of the prophet is known to have lifted.
and things the practice makes obligatory that the book has left free to leave.
There are duties fixed to their appointed times that fall away when their time has passed.
It marks off the forbidden acts one from another, the great sins against which it threatens the fire, and the small ones for which it holds out hope of forgiveness, and it names acts acceptable in their lesser measure and left open in their greater, binding in neither.
Well, I mean, the sheer weight of that silence after the text ends is palpable.
We are sitting here looking at a massive, complex piece of literature, and it demands a total shift in how we listen.
I am struck by the compiler making such a deliberate, almost jarring choice to place this first in the collection.
Yeah, I hear you.
It is entirely jarring for a reader.
Because, you know, this is a text renowned globally as a masterful guide on governance, on the ordering of a society, on ethics and statecraft.
So a reader picks this up expecting rules, laws, or maybe a treatise on how to manage an economy.
Instead, the Imam, peace be upon him, opens with a paradox that essentially paralyzes the tongue.
He is using this incredibly elevated speech to announce that speech itself can deliver absolutely nothing of the creator.
And the architecture of that failure is mapped out so precisely in those first few lines.
It is crucial to understand that it's not just a general statement of human modesty.
We are not just hearing someone say.
Like A generic poetic humility.
Precisely.
The Imam provides 3 parallel clauses and each one dismantles a specific human faculty.
First, praising is defeated.
He says, whose laudation those who speak cannot deliver.
The very office of words, the mechanics of language which exist to carry meaning from one mind to another breaks down completely.
Okay, so language is the first casualty.
Then, second, reckoning is defeated.
whose graces those who count cannot number.
So the mathematical mind, the human faculty that measures, categorizes, and divides reality into understandable units, is overwhelmed.
And finally, requital is defeated.
whose rightful do those who strive cannot render?
So even physical exertion falls short.
Physical exertion, moral effort, the entirety of a creature's attempt to repay its creator through action.
It all fails.
Those 3 defeats, words, measure, and effort encompass the entirety of what a created being can offer.
The complete map of the creature's poverty is drawn in the very first breath of the text.
But I don't buy that yet.
If no word can reach God, how is the whole sermon not self-defeating?
How do you mean?
Well, we are presented with a massive, incredibly eloquent sermon
describing God in intricate detail.
If praise fails so utterly, why deliver this expansive oration of praise at all?
It seems to contradict its own premise in the act of being spoken.
That tension you were pointing out is the exact engine driving the text.
The claim here is a work of rigorous logic, not mere poetic humility.
The speaker is establishing A foundational ontological reality.
Before a person can rule an empire rightly, before they can act justly in a courtroom or even know their own self, they must first stand rightly before the real.
I see.
So it is foundational to everything else.
And standing rightly begins with recognizing the absolute hard limit of the human mind.
The sermon must use words to guide the listener up to the very precipice where words fail.
The speech is a ladder designed to be climbed, and the higher you climb, the less luggage you are allowed to carry.
The less luggage, I like that.
So the words are entirely functional.
They serve only to bring the intellect to the edge of its own limitation.
Can we unpack this ladder analogy a bit more?
Let's look at the first governing analogy the text presides for this ascent, which is an ascending ladder with strict sequential rungs.
The text states, the foremost of religion is the knowledge of him.
That is the first rung on the ladder.
But knowledge can be purely abstract.
It can be just a collection of facts in your head.
So we step up to the next rung.
The perfection of knowing him is to believe in him.
Belief requires the heart's assent, moving beyond mere intellectual data into personal conviction.
Then we step up again.
The perfection of believing in him is to affirm his oneness.
Progression tightens dramatically there.
It moves from a generalized belief in a higher power to a specific, unified, piercing focus.
You cannot just believe in a fragmented pantheon.
You must unify the vision.
Correct.
And from affirming oneness, we move to the penultimate run.
The perfection of affirming his oneness is to be sincere toward him.
Sincerity here is not just earnestness.
It means stripping away the ego, purifying the intention so that the devotion is solely exclusively for the one.
Okay, I follow the climb so far.
And this leads to the final, astonishing summit of the ladder.
The perfection of sincerity toward him is to divest him of all attributes.
The climb does not end in a more vivid picture of God.
It does not end in a more detailed, colorful description.
The perfection of knowing, believing, and being sincere results in the complete and total stripping away of every description.
I have to stop you there.
If we divest him of all attributes, doesn't that strip away his mercy, his power, his life?
How is that not denying who he is?
It is a terrifying prospect for the mind, isn't it?
Very much so.
If we follow this rigorous logic to its absolute end, it sounds as though we are forbidden from calling him compassionate or powerful or all-knowing.
We lose the very qualities that make any kind of relationship with the divine possible.
I mean, a believer relies upon the mercy of God.
To divest him of it feels like, well, theological vandalism.
Let's carefully steel man that fear because it is the most natural human reaction to this text.
We are terrified of losing the personal God.
We are wired psychologically to put a face on things.
It is the classic old man with a beard sitting on a cloud problem.
Because we need something to grasp onto.
Exactly.
Wait, excuse me.
I mean, that is the core of it.
Human beings understand power by looking at a powerful king.
We understand mercy by looking at a forgiving parent.
We take these finite, bounded experiences, stretch them out as far as our imagination allows, and paste them onto God.
But the teaching here does not deny that God is merciful or powerful or living.
What is denied is the pictured bounded quality that our mind constructs when we hear those words.
Let's pause on that term for a moment, the bounded quality.
For you listening and trying to grasp this, what exactly constitutes a bounded quality?
Think about human mercy.
When a human feels mercy, it is a finite emotion.
It is a feeling that arises in reaction to a specific situation.
It swells, it peaks, and eventually it fades.
It has a beginning and an end.
It is a bounded thing.
It's reactionary.
Yes, and we picture this human quality and project it onto the infinite creator.
It is that pictured limited boundary that the imam is rejecting.
The text argues that every attribute bears witness that it is other than the object it qualifies.
The adjective is not the noun.
Therefore, whoever ascribes an attribute to God has joined another to him.
The logic is unforgiving.
If God is the subject and you attach an attribute as something distinct from his essence, like applying a coat of paint to a wall, you have created a duality.
You have the essence and then you have the attribute floating alongside it.
And whoever joins another to him has made him too.
Whoever makes him too has divided him into parts.
And whoever divides him into parts is entirely ignorant of him.
Let's use a modern translation here.
Think about building a car.
A car is composite.
It's made of an engine, wheels, a chassis.
If you take away the wheels, it ceases to function as a car.
The car relies on its parts to exist.
If God is made of mercy plus power plus knowledge, then God depends on these distinct parts to be God.
The parts would precede him.
Which shatters the concept of an ultimate singular uncaused source.
Precisely.
The boundary is false, not the reality.
The mind's limit is rejected so that what remains is a mercy that is nothing other than God himself, entirely unfragmented.
So we are not negating the reality of the mercy, but rather the human scale of the mercy we inherently imagine.
We are chipping away the marble of our own assumptions.
That is the exact mechanism.
The tradition inherited this exact mode of approaching the divine.
The Imam opens his magnificent prayers on precisely this note.
He speaks of the God whom the sight of onlookers fall short of reaching and whom the imaginations of those who would describe him are powerless to render.
So the lineage maintains this rigor.
The entire spiritual lineage speaks with this unified grammar of awe.
They do not praise by claiming to comprehend.
They praise by consessing the total powerlessness of the human imagination.
The Imam systematically dismantles our spatial and limiting concepts.
He says whoever points to him has confined him.
Confined him because pointing implies a coordinate, it draws a border.
You point to an object that occupies a specific volume of space, distinguishing it from the empty space around it.
To point to the boundless is to immediately fundamentally misunderstand what boundless means.
And whoever confines him has counted him, treated him as just one object among many objects in a series.
Whoever asks, in what is he,
encloses him like putting a letter in an envelope.
Whoever asks upon what is he sets him apart, implying he requires a foundation like a chair to rest upon.
Every single mental construct, every categorical box the human mind has evolved to use is taken apart here.
That sounds like wordplay isn't stripping every attribute, just a fancy way of saying God is bare nothingness.
I mean, if we say
He is not this and not that and we cannot point to him and he is not in a place and we must strip away every descriptive word.
At the end of that rigorous process, the mind is staring into a blank void.
It feels like emptiness.
It feels practically indistinguishable from non-existence.
If we remove all categories of being as our brains understand them, aren't we just left with nothing?
That is the great peril of the human mind encountering the infinite.
We confuse the absence of a limit with the absence of reality.
Because our brains only know how to process limits, when the limit is removed, our brain screams, void, nothingness.
But the negation happening here is actually the near side of affirmation.
How so?
Let's look at the second governing analogy embedded deeply in this tradition.
The primary testimony of faith itself, the declaration there is no God but God.
The structure of that testimony is entirely built on a sweeping away.
There is no God.
The negation comes first.
It is aggressive.
It sweeps away every idol the imagination sets up, every false boundary, every lesser concept of power or security you might rely on.
But it does not end in a void.
The sweeping away is immediately followed by the confessing.
but God.
So the affirmation requires the destruction of the false first.
The sole reality is affirmed only after the space has been ruthlessly cleared of the idols of the mind.
Applied to the attributes, the rhythm is the identical mechanism.
There is no all compassionate but God.
The merely pictured bounded mercy is denied.
So the infinite ontological reality of mercy can finally be affirmed.
So the negation is a preparatory act.
It clears the false so the true can have room to be acknowledged.
An Ismaili philosopher from the tradition articulated this brilliantly, using a double negation to prevent the mind from falling into the trap of thinking God is a void.
He taught that the tongue must negate twice.
God is not a thing, and he is not a thing.
Let's unpack that logic because it is vital.
Not a thing clears away the crude physical idol.
It destroys the idea that God is an object in the universe, a being among beings.
But the second part, not a thing, is the ultimate safeguard.
It stops the mind from turning him into non-existent.
Because even the concept of non-existence or nothingness is still a human category.
It is a concept we invented to describe the physical world.
It is a yardstick we use to measure reality within the physical universe.
We evolved to recognize when a predator is in the brush and when there is no predator in the brush.
Existence and non-existence are binaries we apply to creation.
To apply that binary to the creator of the binary is a massive category error.
The first negation clears the physical idol.
The second negation clears the subtle, intellectual idol hiding inside the mind's own denial.
Nothing of the creature's categories is left clinging to the real.
An early Sufi master compressed this entire theological rigor into a single, devastating definition.
He said that divine oneness is to set the eternal apart from all that comes to be in time.
Okay, I concede the point.
The necessity of it is undeniable now.
If you do not perform this rigorous negation, you inevitably drag the eternal down into the timeline of created, decaying things.
You end up worshipping a highly exalted creature, not the creator.
You worship an idol made of thoughts rather than an idol made of wood.
The grammar of the text is working entirely
to prevent that collapse.
Let's examine that grammar directly in the text, because it governs everything the Imam says as he transitions from the abstract essence down into the act of creation.
The text says, he is being, but not through any coming to be.
existent, but not at a former nothingness.
He affirms the reality, and in the exact same breath, he strips away the limit.
It is a deliberate, rhythmic oscillation.
He's with everything, but not by association.
You affirm presence, but you immediately deny physical proximity.
And other than everything, but not by separation.
You affirm transcendence, but you deny spatial distance.
He acts, but not through movements or instruments.
Every single positive claim is immediately rescued from becoming a bounded idol.
This specific grammar affirm, then strip the limit, prepares us for the pivotal moment in the text.
The perfection of sincerity toward him is to divest him of all attributes.
And because he is divested of all attributes, because he is bound by nothing, needs nothing, and undergoes no change whatsoever, his act of creation is entirely unique.
If God acts without movement, without instruments, and without any coming to be,
then creation cannot be an act of necessity.
It cannot be God changing his state from non-creator to creator in order to fulfill a need.
This is a profound departure from ancient mythologies.
In many ancient traditions, the gods create humans because they need labor, or they need sacrifices to feed them, or they create out of a sense of cosmic loneliness.
But the unbounded giver creates not to repair some lack within himself.
The text explicitly states, he is alone, for there was none whose company he might seek or whose absence he might feel.
Therefore, the world that follows from him is a sheer unnecessary gift.
The negation we struggled with at the opening is actually the only mechanism that makes the generosity of creation intelligible.
Only a God who is bound by nothing and needs nothing could give being so freely.
The world is not a symptom of divine necessity or cosmic loneliness.
It is an outpour
provoked absolute generosity.
And the text shifts dramatically here.
Having emptied the listener's mind of every finite concept of God, it descends forcefully into the physical drama of cosmology.
The language moves from silent abstraction to violent thundering motion.
The imam describes God cleaving the atmospheres, splitting the surrounding regions in the layers of air.
The imagery is overwhelmingly forceful, almost terrifying.
Into them he made water flow, its waves surging and swelling, heaped upon the back of a violent, thunderous wind.
We are seeing the raw materials of existence in a state of absolute chaos and turbulence.
It is not a gentle painting of a landscape.
It is a collision of cosmic forces.
God commands a first wind to hold the water back, giving it power over the fury of the currents.
And then we arrive at the third governing analogy of our deep dive.
The imam says God raised up another wind, a barren wind, and ordered it to churn the ways of the sea until it beat them as a milk skin is beaten.
Let's translate that milk skin analogy for a modern listener.
imamate is deeply grounded in the desert reality of the time.
To make butter, you place milk in an animal skin and you agitate it violently.
You subject A homogeneous liquid to extreme kinetic energy, throwing it back and forth, turning it still into moving its first back upon its last.
It is purposeful agitation.
The turbulence is not random.
It has a highly specific purpose.
It is an extraction of order and solidity from a churning fluid.
It forces a phase change.
The chaos of the primordial waters is beaten like that milk skin until it throws up a froth.
And from that very foam of chaos, he lifts the seven heavens.
The lowest becomes a staid wave held back, the highest a roof upheld and a vault raised high.
Notice the trajectory of this creation account.
It goes from chaos to order.
It begins with violent, thunderous wind and surging flooding waves, and it ends with the intricate adornment of stars, a shining lamp, and a luminous moon in a turning orbit.
The narrative moves from maximum turbulence to absolute mathematical serenity.
The sheer violence of the churning sea resolves into the quiet precision of the wheeling firmament.
Creation is revealed not as a gentle act of decoration, but as the total mastery over immense tumult.
And that mastery is absolute, precisely because the one ordering it is bound by nothing within it.
Then, having constructed this vast, serene vault, the text parts the heights of the heavens and fills them with the ranks of angels.
The Imam lingers on these celestial orders, creating a profound hierarchy of devotion.
The text details angels who prostrate and never bow, those who bow and never stand, those who stand in ranks and never break them, they glorify endlessly.
No slumber of the eye, no wandering mind, no physical weariness ever overtakes them.
Their devotion is perpetual and flawless.
There are trustees of revelation, guardians of servants, keepers of gardens, and at the summit of this hierarchy are beings of an unimaginable scale.
Their feet are fixed in the lowest depths of the earth.
Their necks pass beyond the highest heaven.
Between them and all below are veils of majesty and curtains of might.
It is a staggering image of celestial power.
Yet for all this cosmic grandeur, for all their proximity to the divine, the decisive theological point the Imam makes about these highest angels brings us right back to the beginning of the sermon.
The text says, they do not picture
their lord in any form, nor ascribe to him the marks of things made, nor confine him within places, nor point to him by any likeness.
The very creatures standing nearest the throne engage in an apophatic worship.
Their highest adoration is a negative one.
Even with their immense cosmic knowledge, even with their staggering intellects, they do not attempt to draw a boundary around the boundless.
Negation becomes the highest form of worship, not just for the limited human mind, but for the very apex of creation.
Heaven itself is built on this negation.
Their nearness to God is not measured by having a more vivid, high-definition image of him, but by how completely they have surrendered the need to picture him at all.
They practice the exact divesting of attributes that the opening ladder demanded of us.
The smarter the being, the less they try to put God in a box.
From the unimaginable heights of those angels, the narrative zeros in on a handful of dust.
God gathers earth of the hard and the soft, the sweet and the salt.
He pours water over it, kneads it with moisture, shapes a figure with curves and joints, and lets it dry until it rings like fired clay.
The contrast is jarring.
From beings whose necks pass the highest heavens, constructed of pure light and obedience, we move to mud.
Clay kneaded of clashing natures, heat and cold, moisture and dryness, a fragile composite inherently unstable thing.
But then he breathed into it of his spirit.
This clay rises up a human being, endowed with minds to govern its thought, limbs to serve it, and a knowing by which to tell the true from the false.
The breath of the spirit awakens the clay to discernment, and immediately this newly quickened creature becomes the center of a cosmic test.
God commands the tireless, flawless angels to bow down before Adam.
And they all prostrate, except Iblis.
The tension we explored earlier regarding idolatry and the limits of the mind manifests here as a massive moral crisis.
Iblis refuses and the text says pride seized him.
He gloried in his own making of fire and scorned the creature of clay.
Iblis exalted his own substance over the command of God.
He looked at the material fire versus clay and made a judgment based entirely on boundaries, forms, and atomic weight, if you will.
He was the first materialist.
He only saw the ingredients.
He failed to see the breath of the spirit.
He practiced a hidden idolatry, worshiping his own origin rather than submitting to the boundless authority that gave the command.
His ego became his idol, so God grants him a respite that the trial might be completed.
Adam is settled in a secure dwelling, warned of the enemy, but the deception occurs.
The text says Adam bartered certainty for doubt and resolve for weakness.
He took dread in place of gladness and remorse in place of pride.
It is the tragedy of the fall, beautifully and painfully compressed.
But God spreads his repentance before him, teaches him the word of mercy, and sends him down to the abode of trial and the begetting of children.
The human story, with all his messiness and clashing natures, truly begins in this descent.
And from among Adam's children, the final movement of the text unfolds.
succession of the prophets.
The imam describes a world that has largely forgotten its origin.
Most of the creatures had broken their covenants, set up rivals, and the devils had turned them from the knowledge of God.
The idols of the mind that we discussed at the very beginning had manifested as literal idols in the physical world.
So God chooses messengers.
He sends them one after another.
Their mission is defined precisely.
to call humanity, to fulfill the covenant, to remind them of the forgotten gift, and to argue with them by delivering the message.
Most importantly, the text says they are sent to stir up for them the buried treasures of the intellect.
The buried treasures of the intellect, that phrasing is so vital.
The intellect here isn't just an organic calculator in the skull.
It is an intuitive organ for recognizing truth.
It is a faculty meant to climb the ladder we discussed.
The capacity to recognize the unbounded God, to climb that initial ladder, is already
within humanity, but it is buried under the debris of clashing natures, earthly desires, and false imaginings.
The prophets do not bring an alien foreign data set.
They excavate what the soul already knows.
They show the signs of his power, the sky spread above, the earthly beneath, the means of living, the inevitability of death.
And there is a single, unbroken chain of succession.
Each earlier prophet is given the name of the one to come, and each later one confirms the one before.
The generations pass, ages run on, until God sends the Prophet peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
The arrival of the Prophet is the culmination of this immense historical chain.
He is sent to fulfill the promise, his pledge already taken, his signs well known, and he arrives in a world fractured by scattered creeds and divided desires.
The Imam describes the exact nature of those warring ways.
Some likening God to his creation, some twisting his name, some pointing to another than him.
Notice how all these errors are variations of the very idolatry the first sentences of the sermon sought to destroy.
They are failures of negation.
They are failures to divest the attributes.
By the prophet, God guided them out of error and delivered them from ignorance.
And then, having completed his immense mission, God chose for him the meeting with himself.
He drew him away from the place of trial and honor.
But a prophet cannot leave a community untended.
The arc of the narrative must land somewhere concrete for the people left behind.
And it lands on the book.
The text shifts one final time, detailing what the prophet left among the people.
The book of your Lord, setting forth it's lawful and it's forbidden, it's obligatory and it's recommended, it's particular and it's general, it's unbound and it's bound.
The sermon that began in the dizzying heights of an incomprehensible essence now grounds itself in the granular daily details of a legal and moral code.
The structure of the book as described by the imam is intricate and highly demanding.
It marks off forbidden acts, threatens the fire for great sins, holds out hope for small ones.
It names acts acceptable in lesser measure and left open in greater.
It is a text that binds and frees, providing a plain Rd.
and a standing beacon.
This ending is deeply intentional.
The boundless God pours out a world, places an intellect within it, guides it through the long labor of prophets across time, and leaves it with a book.
The written word is left in human hands.
And in his own farewell, the prophet named 2 weighty things left behind.
The book of God and his family.
The living guardianship in the written text unified.
The voice delivering this very sermon is the voice of that guardianship, unpacking the depths of the book.
The ark is perfectly complete.
The sermon is 1 vast, unbroken motion.
The knowledge of God that was declared the foremost of religion at the very beginning is the exact same knowledge that the prophets labored to restore, and it is the exact same knowledge codified in the book.
The end of the sermon loops flawlessly back to its first sentence.
The negation and the creation are not two distinct subjects.
They are one unified teaching.
Before a ruler issues a decree, before justice can be enacted in the world, the soul must let go of the idols the mind naturally manufactures.
A ruler who serves a bounded picture of God, a God he thinks he can comprehend and contain, will inevitably serve an idol of his own power, his own certainty, or his own tribe.
The perfection of sincerity toward him is to divest him of all attributes.
The journey ends not in grasping the divine, but in allowing oneself to be unmade by the boundless real.
Which idol of the mind, which small bounded picture of the real, does your own worship still serve this week?